(sirens wailing)
- What beautiful symbolism.
The day after Thanksgiving
your head might feel like that.
Get rid of the evidence and
replace it with cute sh--
(cymbal crashes)
Hello and welcome to this video!
It is almost Thanksgiving and
or Thanksgiving has already
happened for you.
Either way, food! And regret.
And tolerance.
The circle of life on any given holiday.
That's what the holidays
are really all about,
the endless cycle of
consumption and repression.
One of the best things about the holidays,
other than the quality time
you spend with your family,
is leftovers.
And so today I'm gonna teach
you how to turn your holiday
leftovers into something delicious.
Basically, this is just a
means to get all of it back
in your face again.
And what better way than nachos!
So today we're going to
make ThanksGimmeDozeNachos
using all of your leftovers
from Thanksgiving.
I don't have leftovers
because I didn't make the
holiday meal, domestic
goddess-in-training I guess,
but did you see this?
So I bought some store bought things.
Mashed potatoes, stuffing. Oh, no.
I actually did get stuff to
make a green bean casserole.
Why did I do that?
And I don't have turkey so
I got turkey burger patties
that I'm gonna cook right now.
That's the first step.
Is cooking the turkey burger
patties and I guess making a
green bean casserole? Goddammit.
So hopefully you won't
have to do this part,
everything will be cooked
for you because your spoiled,
(stove top snapping)
I mean loved.
(snapping stops)
No snaps for that?
We got this.
Is there any directions
on the can anywhere?
Any helpful directions on
the can, absolutely none.
Haha.
Just like your relatives.
Casserole, that looks like it.
I actually made a video making
this last year with my mother
so that shows you how good my
listening skills are around
my mother, I love you mom.
Oh, that looks like seaweed.
Then you take cream of mushroom,
I think, and then you pour that in?
Oh, yes, cool.
(disgusted sounds)
I remember this part of the video.
(retching noises)
That's what my grandfather
used to do to me when I would
eat chocolate pudding
mixed with whipped cream
and I would mix it up.
He would come behind me and just go
(retching noises)
I think were suppose to mix
like garlic power and salt
and pepper in that then.
Put some salt, pepper,
and garlic powder. Right?
Do as I googled, not as I do.
We do have time for some of these though.
Crispy fried onion toppings.
Why don't we use these all
year around for everything,
why are they only for Thanksgiving?
Because we're awful?
There you go, see what happens.
Best of luck to you!
Okay, now on to the turkey.
Oh, that's hot. Okay.
(pan sizzles)
Whoa!
Okay. We'll just do two.
Now we wash our hands.
'Tis the season for season...ing.
Do I put all spice on it?
I feel like...
Ugh, ahh, yeah no.
Cooking , we're cooking!
Whoa, that looks like a diet.
You won't have to do this part,
your turkey will already be done.
Wanna see a dramatization
of how I act around
family over the holidays?
(silence)
Thank you, I know I'm a great actress.
Okay, let's just get on with it.
(laughs)
That's how I start every Thanksgiving.
The green bean casserole is
just finishing in the oven
and I have ground my turkey
patties and they're cooling
off in the refrigerator.
So let's make these ThanksGimmeDozeNachos!
For our base, I'm using these buddies.
It's pumpkin chips! Look at them.
All at them. Awww.
These might sound disgusting to you
but these are so delicious.
Chips!
Next, you're gonna just throw
everything together on this
like nachos.
Nachos are a beautiful meal
because it is reflective
of my personality.
Sloppy, chaotic, and just so delicious.
Let's throw down some mashed potatoes.
That looks like mashed potatoes.
Looks like I'm not the whitest
thing in the kitchen anymore.
Heh.
Uh oh, oh no.
Okay, these are
(disgusted sound)
Maybe these should've
got heat up a little bit.
Ugh, oh my god.
What are you?
I'm gonna put these in the microwave.
This is becoming complicated.
This was supposed to be so easy!
Just like family.
Goddammit, are you gonna have
to go in the microwave too?
Probably.
Not going as planned, thank
god I have a Diet Dr Pepper.
Can you imagine if this
was just one Diet Dr Pepper
commercial?
This is not a commercial,
it's not sponsored at all.
Why did I give them that free promo?
(facepalms)
My house is haunted.
They're just chips,
they're not nachos yet.
(chip falls)
(laughs)
Our mashed potatoes are
kinda warmish so let's just
put a little bit down because
these are not delicious.
That looks like something.
Now let's take our casserole out.
That looks like a thing!
Whoa, yeah.
Next, let's throw some turkey in here.
Get it turkeys.
Now let's get our stuffing.
Let's taste you.
Great.
There goes the stuffing. Yup.
Oh, it's not that bad.
Turns out your body gets
use to the terrible flavor.
Now the turkey gravy,
are you suppose to get microwaved?
Let's microwave you for a second.
And then we can put cheese
on as a binding agent.
I got six cheese Italian
because I don't know what to do.
Uh, sure.
Drizzle some gravy on.
That's the great thing about nachos,
is that you can put them
together anyway you want to.
Don't let your Aunt
Cathy tell you otherwise.
We're gonna put these now in
the broiler for a little bit
so that all of the
things come together for
a brief moment in time.
Just like family!
(sirens wailing)
Uh oh, that's my ride.
Just kidding. Good luck with your life.
I think it's ready.
Cool!
And there you go, ThanksGimmeDozeNachos!
Let's taste it, you wanna taste it?
Cheers
- Cheers
Mmmmm!
I had a good chip.
If it was made with better
mashed potatoes it would be
really, really good.
- Yeah, tastes like Thanksgiving.
- ThanksGimmeDozeNachos,
make them yourself.
Put them places on the
internet, tag me in your photos.
It's not the worst thing
in the whole world.
And the nachos are pretty good too.
Aayooo, I don't know.
I'll just come back when
all of this is done.
How 'bout that?
Is how Thanksgiving
should go with the family,
Let's just get back to each
other after we're done eating
our feellings.
Then we'll have a couple
minutes of conversation
then we'll just go.
Holidays!